IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBO
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBY
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBB
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBT
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBH
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBM
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBE
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOBF
IT WAS HIGHER LOYALTY IS TO NOB.
JOINING ME NOW FOR A REACTION TO
ALL OF THIS IS FORMER
CONGRESSMAN AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR TREY GOWDY.
I SERVED WITH MR. GOTTI ON THE
CONGRESS AND IT WAS A PLEASURE
TO DO SO AND TRY, I APPRECIATE
YOU COMING HERE.
I LOVE THE GLASSES.
IT'S A GOOD LOOK.
>> I LOVE YOU TOO JASON.
>> Jason: YOU HAVE READ
THROUGH THE REPORT.
YOU HAVE DEALT PERSONALLY WITH
MR. DIRECTOR CALLED ME OVER A
SERIES OF YEARS.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE AWAY FROM WHAT
MR. HOROWITZ CONCLUDED?
>> HE IS A TWO-TIME OFFENDER.
REMEMBER HOROWITZ ALSO IS DEEMED
FOR HIS HANDLING OF THE CLINTON
EMAIL INVESTIGATIONS AND HOW HE
GETS DINGED IN THE OTHER MAJOR
CASES HANDLED IN 2016.
I NEVER SAID COMEY WOULD OR
SHOULD GO TO JAIL.
I'M CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
APOLOGIZE TO ANYONE WHO VIOLATED
SPI AND DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
POLICIES, WHO VIOLATED AN
EMPLOYMENT AGREEMENT, WHO
SHARED SENSITIVE INFORMATION
ABOUT AN ONGOING INVESTIGATION,
WHO SENT CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
TO AN UNAUTHORIZED PERSON AND
THEN HAD AMNESIA WHEN THE FBI
CAME TO HIS HOME TO TRY TO
RETRIEVE GOVERNMENT PROPERTY.
I'M NOT GOING TO APOLOGIZE BUT I
WILL GIVE HIM A PIECE OF
UNSOLICITED ADVICE.
JASON, YOU REFERENCED COMEY'S
OBSESSION WITH HIS HIGHER
ETHICAL STANDINGS THAN THE REST
OF US HAVE SO HERE'S MY ADVICE.
IF YOU SHOULD ASPIRE TO MORE IN
LIFE THAN SIMPLY SKATING BY
WITHOUT HAVING BEEN INDICTED.
IF THAT IS YOUR GOAL IN LIFE TO
JUST NOT MEET EVERY ESSENTIAL
ELEMENT OF A CRIMINAL OFFENSE
AND YOU THINK YOU SHOULD BE
CONGRATULATED AND APOLOGIZED TO
FOREST SIMPLY BECAUSE YOU WERE
NOT INDICTED, YOU BETTER GIVE
BACK SOME OF THOSE HIGHER
LOYALTIES SPEAKING FEES.
>> Jason: YEAH, YOU KNOW, IT'S
INTERESTING THIS LITTLE NUANCE
PART ABOUT WHEN THE FBI DID GO
TO HIS HOME.
AS AN FBI DIRECTOR, HE DOES GET
A SKIFF, AS SECURED COMPARTMENT
ALL INFORMATION FACILITY BUT HE
EVIDENTLY TOOK THIS INFORMATION
AND DIDN'T KEEP IT THERE.
HE KEPT IT IN HIS OWN PERSONAL
ESSAYS SUPPOSEDLY.
THAT'S A REAL PROBLEM.
IMAGINE IF EVERY FEDERAL
EMPLOYEE DID THAT.
>> WELL, IT'S NOT A PROBLEM IF
YOU CONSIDER IT TO BE YOUR OWN
PERSONAL DIARY.
IT DEPENDS ON WHAT THE RECORD
SAID.
TO THE RECORD SAY DEAR DIARY,
CONGRESS WAS MEAN TO ME TODAY
BUT I DIDN'T GET TALK TO THE
PRESIDENT?
THAT MIGHT BE A PERSONAL DIARY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS WAS.
HE IS TALKING TO HIS BOSS.
HE'S TALKING TO THE HEAD OF THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND THEN HE
MEMORIALIZES IT INTO PUBLIC
RECORD.
NO MATTER WHAT HE CALLS IT, THAT
RECORD BELONGS TO THE
UNITED STATES SO HE CAN CALL IT
A DIARY LIKE A BIRTHDAY CARD AND
OTHER CORRESPONDENCE BUT NOBODY
OTHER THAN JIM COMEY CONSIDERS
THAT TO BE PERSONAL.
>> Jason: DO YOU THINK THERE
WAS THE ACCOUNTABILITY AND THE
CONSEQUENCE?
YOU KNOW THE CRITICISM HERE IS
THAT IF SOMEBODY ELSE HAD DONE
THIS, THEY WOULD BE IN
HANDCUFFS.
THEY WOULD BE GOING TO JAIL.
BUT IS JUSTICE BEING FAIR AND
RIGHT HERE AND IS HE BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE?
>> WELL, I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO
THAT.
WHEN OUR FELLOW CITIZENS THINK
WE HAVE A TWO TRACK JUSTICE
SYSTEM, EITHER FOR THE FAMOUS OR
THE NOT FAMOUS OR THE RICH OR
THE POOR, THEN WE ARE IN TROUBLE
AS A REPUBLIC PRAYED I WOULD
WOULD TUMBLING FELLOW CITIZENS
THIS.
WE HAVE TO HAVE OTHER WAYS OF
MEETING ON A CALENDAR ABILITY
OTHER THAN SIMPLY INDICTMENTS
BUT HILLARY CLINTON WAS NEVER
INDICTED PITCH WAS NEVER CHARGED
THEREFORE NEVER GUILTY OF A
CRIME BUT YET THE AMERICAN JURY
IN 2016 METED OUT A CONSEQUENCE.
JIM COMEY, WHETHER HE LIKES IT
OR NOT, ALL OF HIS PADS IN THE
SOUTHERN DISTRICT OF NEW YORK
FROM ALL OF HIS PAST AT THE
INJUSTICE, ALL OF HIS TIME AS AN
FBI DIRECTOR, SOME OF WHICH I
AGREED WITH, ALL OF THAT WILL BE
FORGOTTEN.
GONE AND HISTORY WILL BE ALL OF
OUR JUDGES BUT THEY WILL JUDGE
JIM COMEY BASED ON THE FACT THAT
HE GOT DINGED ON BOTH OF THE
MAJOR INVESTIGATIONS HE WAS
HANDLING IN 2016 BY THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THAT WILL BE THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND THAT'S WHAT HISTORY WILL
REMEMBER ABOUT JIM COMEY.
>> Jason: LAST QUICK QUESTION
FOR YOU.
MR. COMEY ACTUALLY EXPECTS YOU
TO APOLOGIZE.
ARE YOU READY TO APOLOGIZE
TONIGHT?
>> WHAT TEMPERATURE IS IT IN
HELL RIGHT NOW?
IS IT SNOWING?
WHEN IT SNOWS AND HOW, YOU LET
ME KNOW.
WHY WOULD I APOLOGIZE TO
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN DINGED ON
BOTH OF THE MAJOR INVESTIGATIONS
BY A GUY LIKE MICHAEL HOROWITZ
WHO IS HARDLY A REPUBLICAN?
HE WAS PICKED BY OBAMA AND
CONFIRMED BY THE SON AND I THINK
WITHOUT A DISSENTING VOTE.
THAT'S WHO SAID HE WAS SCREWED
UP JIM COMEY.
IT WASN'T A REPUBLICAN
CONGRESSMAN.
>> Jason: I THINK YOU AND I
WERE BOTH ON THAT BANDWAGON BUT
YOU ARE RIGHT.
HORWITZ, AN IMPECCABLE
CREDENTIAL APPOINTED BY OBAMA
AND CONFIRMED UNANIMOUSLY BY THE
UNITED STATES AND A PRETTY EVEN
CALL ME PRAISE THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
HE'S NOW BEEN ON THE RECEIVING
END OF TWO INSPECTOR GENERAL
REPORTS AND MORE TO COME.
>> Jason: HE'S A TWO-TIME
CAREER OFFENDER.